a large number of unemployed nevadans
are suddenly being told they owe money
to the state the messages this week
as you can imagine they were a surprise
since those people haven't received the
money they're owed yet
those people were told they are not
eligible for unemployment funds
we spoke to justin rodriguez he is an
entertainer he was told he did not
qualify for the pandemic unemployment
assistance fund
but he got two letters saying he must
now pay the money he never got
back he doesn't know if it's something
that should be appealed
i'm asking to be paid back money that i
never received part of me says
okay let's get this appeal and let's
make sure that they just know that
they're asking me for money back that i
that they never paid me on the other
hand it's like who the heck is even
paying attention to any of us anymore a
lot of frustration we did reach out to
the state and whether people can appeal
state told us they are working on
answering our questions so as soon as we
get answers we will let you know